an alleged murder For Hire plot the
victim's two children according to
police thanks for joining us at six I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus these
are new allegations against a man
already accused of killing his
girlfriend a news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy obtained a document
detailing the allegations against Philip
O'Reilly
police say it was here at the jail where
Philip O'Reilly tried to hire another
inmate to kill four people including two
children O'Reilly wanting them to
disappear to help beat his current
charges O'Reilly is accused of murdering
his girlfriend Cheryl Lynn beardall in
Henderson in 2020. police say he beat
her with a dog leash this was initially
a missing person's case O'Reilly now
faces numerous counts including murder
child abuse sex crimes against children
and now soliciting for murders Metro
Police say earlier this month he told
another inmate he'd pay him twenty
thousand dollars to kill the potential
Witnesses and he provided an address and
map police also say they have evidence
like an audio recording discussing a
timeline of when he wanted the murders
done video and more according to
detectives O'Reilly told the inmate he
previously paid someone to commit the
murders but instead that person stole
his money also when and the other inmate
asked O'Reilly are you sure this is what
you want O'Reilly responded 100
000 percent said Nevada versus Philip
O'Reilly this is O'Reilly in court last
week it appears negotiations may be
underway meaning his defense attorney
may be trying to work out a deal with
prosecutors O'Reilly is scheduled to
appear back in court in May detectives
say on March 16th they notified
O'Reilly's targets the two adults that
O'Reilly was plotting to kill them and
the two children these are beardalls
family members and in another twist in
this case beardall's body has never been
found the question could these possible
negotiations involve O'Reilly telling
police where her body may be reporting
in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now